bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7 8
l'actu sur tvfils 78 le journal de la
rédaction nous allons faire le tour des
principales informations de ce jour en
ce lundi 24 février nous débutons par
ces jeunes majeurs sans papier qui ont
rencontré leur nouveau parrain et
marraine depuis plusieurs années le
Réseau éducation sans frontière des
Yvelines organise ce type de rencontre
pour protéger les jeunes scolarisés qui
vivent sous la menace d'une expulsion
les précisions de Yolaine Torres
à Versailles ce lundi 17 jeunes majeurs
sans papiers ont été parrainés un
événement organisé par le Réseau
éducation sans frontières depuis
plusieurs années l'objectif protéger ses
jeunes en cas d'interpellation et agir
pour leur régularisation c'est en tout
cas le rôle de chaque parent et marraine
comme Nicole Bock marraine d'un jeune
lycéen en première année de CAP
mécanique il peut nous appeler n'importe
quand il a tenu il ou elle a notre
numéro de téléphone et on peut aussitôt
intervenir en fonction de la nature du
problème s'il est arrêté etc on est là
pour le soutenir et c'est important pour
eux de savoir qu'il y a des adultes qui
s'engagent à leur côté lorsqu'ils
étaient mineurs la moitié de ces jeunes
était pris en charge par l'aide sociale
à l'enfant mais une fois majeur il n'en
bénéficie plus et se retrouve confrontés
à des difficultés chaque jeune a deux
parents un citoyen qui le suit et un élu
pour un rôle plus symbolique ils font le
marché pour pouvoir m'aider pour pouvoir
continuer mes études
une dizaine d'autres majeurs seront
parrainés d'ici quelques jours
quelle stratégie pour le modem lors de
ces élections municipales dans le
département des Yvelines la formation
sans triste fondée par François Bayrou
se divise en fonction des villes entre
alliance avec l'UMP et alliance avec le
PS le Modem qui est toujours dans le
département va aussi changer de
président Bruno Tabary en poste depuis
2011 a décidé de passer la main le
porte-parole de la formation
vice-président aussi assure l'intérim il
le cache pas ses ambitions je reçois
Bruno milienne bonsoir à vous bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau expliquez-nous
tout d'abord la raison de ce changement
de président déjà elle a raison pour
laquelle Bruno Tabary a décidé de vous
demander d'assurer un petit peu
l'intérim je précise que Bruno Tabary
est aussi candidat à plaisir lui sur une
liste socialiste on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler voilà donc Bruno Bruno m'a
demandé de d'assurer l'intérêt puisque
les élections auront lieu au mois de
juin parce que d'abord il est très
occupé par sa campagne
au bureau du 78 donc Bruno lui est très
occupé par sa campagne vous en doutez
plaisir c'est une grosse ville moi j'ai
pas je suis pas dans le même cas je suis
dans un tout petit village donc j'ai un
petit peu plus de et comme j'ai plus de
temps j'ai essayé de mettre un petit peu
au service de tous nos candidats qui
sont sur différents listes il y a quand
même 87 candidats modernes même s'il n'y
a pas de tête de lit ça fait beaucoup
quand même pour le département avec des
fortunes diverses souvent ça se passe
très très bien et voilà donc j'ai
proposé effectivement à Bruno quand il
m'en a parlé sur l'intérim sans aucun
souci pour aider les gens ça traduit pas
un malaise au sein du MoDem avec
quelques fois des alliances sur
certaines listes avec le PS quelquefois
avec l'UMP également
vous poser cette question ça se traduit
au National ça se traduit aussi au
niveau départemental le National bon
vous le savez en ce moment il y a
l'histoire marseillaise donc ça c'est un
petit peu plus important mais nous il y
a pas vraiment il y a pas vraiment de
problème qui soutient la candidature
plutôt socialiste il y a pas vraiment de
problème sur les Yvelines si vous
regardez bien aller à plus de 85 88% les
alliances elles se font soit avec l'UMP
soit avec l'UDI soit avec les deux donc
de ce côté là il y a pas vraiment de
souci après tout de même à mort pas par
exemple c'est une liste divers gauche
sur laquelle plutôt travaux sur laquelle
on trouve un candidat du MoDem sur la
ville de Plaisir Bruno thabarit qui est
donc est encore le président jusqu'au
mois de juin enfin en tout cas vous
assurez l'intérim mais il est candidat
sur une socialiste face à une liste
umpudi alors je vais vous expliquer il y
a quelques cas je vais vous expliquer ça
très calmement vous savez qu'il y a un
travail municipal qui a été fait on est
en fin de mandature il y a donc déjà il
y a six années qui se sont écoulées il y
a des liens qui se sont tissés il y a
des projets en commun qui se sont faits
sur certaines villes et il y a des
alliances et des amitiés c'est des
histoires d'hommes aussi c'est ce qu'on
disait déjà la dernière fois qui se sont
tissés sur certaines villes c'est le cas
plaisir c'est le cas Villepreux aussi
par exemple ou à Maurepas et ces gens-là
vont sur un projet qui leur paraît
cohérent moi là-dessus j'ai pas j'ai pas
grand chose à dire si le projet leur
paraît plus cohérent que chez le copain
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la politique
politicienne et la politique de partie à
assumer absolument les décisions qui
sont prises par le National le National
ils sont pas sur le terrain avec nous et
avec les habitants des Yvelines donc on
fait là où on pense être le mieux le
plus à même d'apporter ce qu'il faut aux
habitants des différentes communes voilà
il y a eu la création de l'alliance qui
regroupait justement le modem et l'UDI
le but c'était de marcher main dans la
main et aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas oui
mais vous regardez bien sur les Yvelines
c'est le cas c'est le cas de toute façon
quand je vous dis 88% après les les
plaisirs Maurepas Villepreux ces
exemples là sont des exemples de de
travail collaboratif qui a été fait avec
ces élus là déjà depuis très longtemps
pour le bien des habitants donc ça a pas
posé de problème particulier voilà après
le reste on est vraiment dans des
alliances
umpudy je vous le savez
Guyancourt ben on est en alliance avec
l'UMP vous savez aussi qu'à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on va soutenir la
liste de Michel legier donc justement
peut-être une précision parce que vous
parlez de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
récemment dans la presse locale on
pouvait lire qu'il y avait un candidat
du MoDem qui est relié la liste monnaie
par la gauche par le PS ça se fait à
titre personnel
alors ce candidat on peut citer il y a
pas de souci j'ai pas de souci avec lui
jean-marcoursin Jean-Marc on a beaucoup
discuté ensemble on aurait nous aimé au
bureau qui rejoignent la liste de Michel
legier il avait pas envie de le faire
ils avaient pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord tous les deux il a préféré
aller ailleurs il y a aucun souci c'est
son choix je vais pas critiquer les
choix des candidats qu'on a c'est leur
responsabilité mais il était bien
entendu il était d'accord avec ça qu'il
allait en son nom personnel du MoDem
pour autant pour autant du tout donc
c'est là qu'on joue un peuple sur
l'ambiguïté qui est dénoncé aujourd'hui
par Jean-François
vraiment qu'on fasse un distingu entre
les municipales j'ai un sondage là je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure la
préoccupation majeure des Français c'est
pas le parti politique douté
issu le candidat sauf pour les grandes
villes bien évidemment les grandes
villes ça a un enjeu national mais dans
les autres villes en France non ce qui
est important pour les gens c'est
comment la communauté est gérée et
comment les projets sont portés et s'ils
sont réalistes les gens ont besoin
aujourd'hui de ce qui va devenir de
leurs apôts locaux vous comme moi
d'ailleurs tous autant qu'on est ils ont
si besoin d'avoir de la transparence sur
la gestion municipale et voilà tout ça
ça importe aux gens et les projets que
les candidats vont présenter ou que les
listes vont présenter il faut qu'il soit
réalistes et je pense que les gens ont
aussi besoin d'un petit peu de
démocratie participative j'aime pas
beaucoup le terme mais en tout cas
d'être plus impliqué dans la politique
locale qui est plus de sociétés civile
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait et vous
n'êtes pas toujours tendre avec vos
alliés du moment en récemment vous avez
écrit une tribune et je vais vous citer
entre la condescendance de certaines
têtes de listude ou MP à notre égard la
relative bienveillance de celle du PS
qui n'hésiteront pas à un moment venu de
nous planter un coup de poignard dans le
dos que nous reste-t-il c'est la
question que vous posez et ben il nous
reste notre foi et notre volonté de nous
mettre à au service du citoyen c'est là
vous êtes lucide sur les alliances que
vous menez avec ces formations
politiques que ce soit à gauche ou à
droite dans certains endroits on va voir
nous l'important aujourd'hui en tout cas
je vous le dis pour moi l'important
c'est vraiment qu'on ait un maximum il
faut vraiment qu'on ait un maximum
d'élus pour travailler sérieusement au
service du citoyen s'il y a des
dérapages comme on l'a toujours fait on
les signale c'est tout c'est pas une
menace je pense que les gens aujourd'hui
ils voient les gens aujourd'hui ont
envie de voir des politiques
vraiment politiques au service du
citoyen et pas de la politique
politiqueienne ce qu'on promet on le
tient on le tient dans la transparence
dans la gestion du budget municipal qui
est très important c'est difficile en ce
moment il faut pas de dette il faut
faire attention et bien voilà nous on
est là pour ça on a on est assez
innovant demander quand même à pas mal
des gens de de liste de candidats de
tête de liste avec qui on est allié je
pense que les candidats modem dans les
alliances qu'on a conclu ont beaucoup
travaillé et ont amené beaucoup d'idées
et vous arrivez justement vous faire
entendre au sein des différentes listes
qui sont qui sont constituées lorsque
vous arrivez programmatique en général
oui après ça dépend ce qu'on porte comme
idée si on emporte pas beaucoup
évidemment on sera moins entendre mais
en général quand on parle de bonnes
idées on
on se fait entendre aujourd'hui une
modem c'est une formation vraiment
centriste de centre droit ou de centre
gauche alors je vais m'en référer une
récente tribune qui a eu dans Le Nouvel
Observateur un article qui disait que
reste-t-il du MoDem alors les gens
disent évidemment le modèle bah quand
Bayrou en 2012 offert son soutien
François Hollande ils ont dit bah voilà
tous les centres droits sont partis à
l'udié alors maintenant que on est avec
l'Alliance c'est tous les centres gauche
qui s'en vont d'abord un pas de panique
c'est pas vrai d'accord c'est comme dans
tous les partis il y a il y a des gens
qui partent il y a des gens qui
reviennent et on a un taux à peu près
constant de de d'adhérents donc ça ça
bouge pas beaucoup ceux qui sont partis
ont été remplacés et les gens oublient
une chose il y a un noyau dur c'est à
peu près un tiers un tiers un tiers vous
regardez la répartition du MoDem c'est
un tiers de centres droits un tiers de
centre gauche un tiers de centriste
extrémiste on va dire ça comme ça donc
je fais partie et ce tir là il est là
il est là pour vous en tant que cent
triste extrémiste justement de tenir la
maison entre la gauche et la droite ce
qui est difficile ce qui est difficile
et vous le savez très bien c'est de
faire comprendre aux gens que
je vais pas reprendre le terme Nini
parce que ça c'est pas bon nous ce qu'on
veut c'est travailler avec l'ouverture
la plus large possible il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui au niveau national ça
s'est vérifié dans plein de cas les
socialistes nous ont un peu claqué la
porte au nez et nous prennent pas au
sérieux il se trouve qu'on s'est
rassemblé avec les gens de l'UDI et
notamment avec Jean-Louis Borloo qui a
beaucoup de points communs avec François
Bayrou sur la vision politique à la fois
de la France et surtout de l'Europe et
il se trouve qu'on est pas si mal que ça
avec ces gens là finalement il y a peu
de choses qui nous divisent nous ce
qu'on veut c'est bosser bosser bien
redonner ses lettres de noblesse à la
politique et arrêter de polémiquer sur
la politique polynique titienne ça ne
nous intéresse pas bien sûr qu'il y en a
au niveau national je vais pas vous dire
le contraire mais dans le département
mais nous localement mais non mais il y
en a il y en a forcément il y en a
forcément un petit peu mais autant que
faire ce peu on essaye de l'éviter et je
pense que les électeurs municipales
jugeront en fonction des projets en
fonction des campagnes qui seront faites
et si elles sont sincères et réalistes
je suis persuadé qu'il fera le bon choix
merci Bruno Myriam d'être venu en
plateau donc vice-président du MoDem 78
vous assurez l'intérim en ce moment avec
le départ programmé de Bruno à Tabary
merci à vous merci et puis pour suivre
l'actualité de la campagne des
municipales rendez-vous chaque mardi à
18h30 municipale 2014 l'émission le
magazine pour tout savoir de ce qui se
passe dans ce département yvelinois et
n'oubliez pas aussi les débats que nous
organisons chaque mardi chaque jeudi à
20h l'actualité de ce 24 février c'est
aussi la nomination du vicaire général
du diocèse des Yvelines Olivier Le
Borgne au poste d'évêque Damien la
cérémonie d'ordination se déroulera le 6
avril en la cathédrale d'Amiens ordonnée
prêtre en 1991 Olivier Leborgne était le
bras droit de Monseigneur aumônier il a
grandi dans les Yvelines il a été entre
autres responsable local des JMJ en
France en 98 il est aussi prélat
d'honneur du pape depuis 2012 une
distinction honorifique
tout autre sujet cinquième édition de
l'etop c'est le concours international
d'aéromodélisme Clayes-sous-Bois les
pilotes et leurs maquettes qui ont
encore proposé des prestations
spectaculaires qu'on suivait pour nous
Olivier Maniscalco antoniac
nouvel envol pour lithop aux
Clayes-sous-Bois pour sa cinquième et
dernière édition la compétition
internationale d'aéromodélisme a encore
une fois réuni les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux très spectaculaire les
démonstrations de voltigeant offert un
show impressionnant les modélistes
étaient jugés à la fois sur l'épreuve
des figures imposées ou le jurynote sur
la qualité technique et la géométrie
mais aussi sur du vol en musique où les
pilotes proposent un véritable balai
aérien un pilotage exigeant qui requiert
certaines aptitudes il faut avoir de
bons réflexes d'excellents réflexes
parce que de temps en temps on a l'avion
va pas faire exactement ce qu'il faut
donc il faut avoir de très bons réflexes
avec la télécommande
mais c'est surtout une question
d'entraînement à force de faire et puis
surtout savoir construire aussi
parce que souvent ça casse donc il faut
savoir reconstruire
les maquettes fabriquées en plaques de
dépron et en papier Millard matériaux
qui servent d'habitude à l'isolation de
nos maisons font un peu moins d'un mètre
d'envergure pour un poids qui varie
entre 50 et 100 grammes des mesures
peaufinées durant la construction des
modèles réduits ou le moindre réglage
compte c'est principalement des
changements de forme sur l'avion des
améliorations de répartition de surface
et c'est toujours essayer de gagner du
poids parce qu'en Inde plus on est léger
mieux ça vole moi mon avion on va dire
sur le panel ici est assez lourd il fait
80 g mais il est aussi relativement
grand c'est un des plus grands du
circuit 65 participants représentant 15
nationalités différentes concourent lors
de cette hip-hop 2014 si français ont
terminé dans le top 10
[Applaudissements]
un dernier mot de sport avec du basket
le match de la dernière chance pour les
féminines de l'Entente Le Chesnay
Versailles elles se sont imposées face à
Rennes samedi soir et reste donc encore
en course pour se maintient en National
une quelques frayeurs cependant avec une
avance de seulement trois points à la
pause et de deux points à quelques
minutes de la fin score final 71 64 elle
reste donc 11e au général c'est la
première victoire de ces féminines et de
l'Entente Le Chesnay Versailles depuis
quatre mois pour l'essentiel du sport
rendez-vous ce lundi soir avec Anthony
Rech et son 7 8 sport l'actu revient
demain à 18h sur tvfils 78 toutes nos
émissions sont à avoir en replay sur
notre site internet je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]